so um this is a topic that I've been
thinking about for quite a long time and
part of it is spurred by group
discussions in face-to-face groups or in
presentations and then comments that you
get on various videos or posts or
podcasts episodes and I think it's
something that a lot of people get mixed
up about and they end up advocating or
adopting positions that we could call
quasi-stoic they're they're drawing on
stoicism to some degree but they're not
really stoic and they wind up making
mistakes with these important matters of
what we do with other people and the
things that happen to them and so um you
know when Phil pitched this given this
opportunity to lead a conversation with
modern stoicism of all the different
topics that came to mind I thought this
isn't you know I don't know if it's the
most important one the most pressing one
but it's definitely up there in the top
five I would say and it came to mind for
me because I had somebody who weighed in
I think it was a YouTube post I was
posting about something I'd written in
medium and it was about this topic of
you know what do we do when bad things
happen to other people and we're looking
at it from a stoic perspective and this
person was very angry that I could say
that bad things actually happened to
other people and you know they had this
this view that we're going to explore in
just a minute that it's really none of
your business and who are you to call
something bad you know it's it's not
affecting you as such and so I started
thinking about yeah this is a good topic
that we need to get into and I think
it's a perennial topic it's one that
will come up for people over and over
again long after all of us have passed
on
so you know if we think about
um goodness and Badness from a stoic
perspective there's a lot of passages in
stoic authors and literature that if you
read them in isolation they sound as if
goodness and Badness are only to be
found within a person and what's up to
them so you know you may read these
summaries of stoicism virtue is the only
good and vice is the only evil which
isn't actually technically true there's
a lot more involved in that when we dig
into the text but some people will will
say that and you know Epictetus even
says things like that only virtue and
the virtues are genuinely good only
advice and the vices are genuinely bad
everything else is indifferent this is
in discourses 125
um and then you know Epictetus actually
talks about a discourse that anybody
could give about goodness and Badness
into a book book two chapter nine Good
Things Are virtues and everything that
participates in the virtues now notice
that it's not just the virtues anymore
it's what participates in the virtues
and evil are the opposite indifferent
are wealth Health reputation
I think we're all probably familiar with
these sorts of passages
Epictetus also tells us you know a human
being's good and evil lie in what he
calls proy racist which is often
translated as the faculty of choice or
moral uh character or you know there's a
bunch of other things sometimes will is
what people translate it as and all
other things are nothing to us and so
you know when you read stuff like that
and when people put stuff out like that
I think this is one topic where it's
really important not to screw ourselves
up by being the equivalent of a
fundamentalist proof texter somebody who
just looks for isolated little passages
or sound bites or memes because stoicism
is a really rich and complex
philosophical system and practice is
essential to it practice not just by
ourselves but in relation to other
people and so is uh you know committed
and continual study of stoic tax
so if we think about this mistaken point
of view right it's drawing on things
that are coming from stoicism but it's
turning them in in a way that goes
against the rest of it
so a lot of people would say stoicism is
focusing just on what is up to you and
ignoring or putting aside what is not up
to you or is up to other people and so
technically this is what is in the scope
of the prior racist or in your own power
and so we see things like uh you know
being harmed being insulted we should
distinguish the reality of that from our
judgments or our assumptions that we're
actually being harmed or insulted and if
we do that we avoid these bad emotional
states and the stoics of a whole bunch
of these
um you know anxiety anger sadness uh and
why because these stem from wrong
judgments about matters and so how do we
do this we treat everything that is an
indifferent as just being completely
indifferent not making a difference not
having any genuine good or evil to it
just being preferred or rejected perhaps
but those are lesser terms
um now what happens to other people when
we do this
other people strictly speaking and
what's going on with them is not within
the domain of our choice or proiracis
and it it's technically speaking and
indifferent to us so the people that
we're closest to and care most about in
a way if you think about stoicism this
way if bad things happen to them man
that's that's that's their problem right
that's their Affair as a matter of fact
they're not even bad things because if
they really understood matters they
would see that you know losing their job
is not the Calamity that they they think
it is and now is this really stoic is
this how the sage would act no it's not
even how somebody who understands
stoicism you know relatively well would
act and one way that we can think about
this is thinking about
you know yeah other people are mistaken
right it's not stoic to expect other
people who haven't been studying
stoicism to be stoics
so non-stoics and all of us
stoic slobs who are making progress who
aren't the sage right we're going to get
things wrong in our lives and most
people are in fact from the stomach
perspective mistaken about what they
value whether it's genuinely good or bad
and then they're wrong in their
responses and how they uh look at them
and Orient themselves towards them and
what they prioritize so they end up
feeling negative emotions and they end
up making wrong choices and they end up
suffering and they end up doing the
wrong things and they do build bad
habits all of that is real
whether or not they should be doing that
that's a different matter
so you know you could say to that if
you're consistent enough not to be a
hypocrite yourself in doing so which I
wouldn't claim to oh I've got some good
news for you you're not really suffering
you just got matters wrong if you saw
things rightly well you wouldn't be
upset anymore you'd see that the the
things that you think are harms are just
in different matters they don't affect
the core of who you are unless you allow
them to
um but you know the people that are
upset over things a stoics call it
indifference they're they're actually
upset they actually do experience these
negative emotions that's real and they
are harmed in various ways
even a stoic who wants to you know
mistakenly put other people aside could
recognize that by getting things wrong
um they are harming themselves in the
core of who they are and their responses
will gradually make them you know what
stoics consider vicious
um let's so let's take an extreme
example some homeless person who has
been taking care of an animal a dog or a
cat or something like that has had the
animal taken from them and euthanized by
the local police and animal control and
you're sitting there and they're telling
you about it with tears coming down
their face just sobbing
um are you gonna actually tell them oh
you know you haven't really been harmed
and your your pet hasn't really been
harmed either life is an indifferent
um you know no this is a genuine harm to
that person and there's an injustice
that has been imposed on them and their
animal a relationship that has been
forcibly broken and I think there's
something inhuman to expecting others to
behave as stoics when they haven't been
studying or practicing it so if you
think about Epictetus advice and he's
very helpful with this sort of thing he
will say you know your friend has uh had
a a loss in their family go and grieve
with them you know you can actually
groan with them outwardly just don't
groan inwardly it's okay and actually
it's the right thing it's a duty it's a
office it's a appropriate act to go and
grieve with those who are sad so there's
that aspect and then I think to wrap
this up there's you know several
considerations that come straight from
stoic philosophy that we can mull over
in order to become better stoics
so there's I'm going to give you three
but there's many more of these that we
could think of the stoics think of us as
rational beings and being a rational
being means having a social nature not
being an individualist not being
somebody who sets other people aside but
somebody who exists in a fabric of
relationships with other beings from
individuals you know that were say in a
household with or friendly relationships
with all the way up to humanity as a
whole so that's one consideration
another is that if we think that virtue
is you know the most important of the
goods Justice is one of those virtues
and Justice is by its very nature
something that extends to others and has
to do with Arrangements within Society
our interactions with other people
another third thing is and I see some
people asking questions about this
indifference actually do matter they
have some value they just don't have the
same kind of value as virtue and vice do
but they're pretty damn important from a
stoic perspective if you actually look
closely at the stoic text so let's think
about each of these for just a moment in
turn you know with our social nature I'm
sure probably all of you have seen the
diagrams coming from Heracles is
elements of Ethics with the famous
circles and you're supposed to extend
the circles outward that's standard
stoic teaching so we should feel
affection for people which includes
Compassion Care uh concern and this
should extend outward to other people
who we maybe don't know people overseas
even and it doesn't matter whether they
are wrong in
um their perspective on the loss of you
know this thing or that thing we should
recognize that they are suffering the
other thing I want to point out on this
is that the stoics if you read areas
didymus they consider friendship to be
among the good things so it's up there
with virtue and friendship encompasses a
whole range of relationships from what
we normally think of as friendship to
acquaintanceship to hospitality to
kinship even erotic love so that's one
thing then the second thing Justice as a
virtue it's not just an inward
disposition it's not something that we
keep to ourselves by Justice's very
nature it extends outward to other
people
and it tells us how we ought to behave
in relation to them and being you know
kind of a uncompassionate jerk that is
not Justice right
um it's also something that exists
between us human beings and in on duties
which is you know Cicero telling us what
the stoics actually think about the
virtues he points out that leaving other
people to be victims of others Injustice
that's Injustice on our part if my kid
comes to me and says I'm being bullied
at school the right stoic response is
not for me to say oh well these are not
things within our control you're gonna
have to toughen up or something like
that Injustice is being done and I
actually have a duty to oppose that
the last thing the the indifference and
I've actually done entire talks about
why the indifference are not things we
should be indifferent to so there's a
lot more to be said here Cicero points
out again in on the ends that the
virtues what do they actually Bear upon
they they bear upon things that are not
indifference and they're not a
difference but much of the practice of
the virtues has to do with how we deal
with the indifference Prudence Justice
courage and Temperance right each of
those applies to this vast range and
other people are among those right our
relationships with them and what we can
do for them
um Epictetus and here's where I'll just
end he actually tells us that the
essence of good is a certain uh
comportment of our prior racist that of
the evil another kind so what are
external things they're materials for
the proy races in dealing with it it'll
find its proper its idione specific good
or evil and what is it that uh gets us
there judgments dogmata about the
materials if we get them right well they
make the moral purpose good if they're
crooked and screwed up then they make it
evil and I would go so far as to say
that thinking that stoicism demands that
we be indifferent to the sufferings of
others to bad things happening to them
even if we want to say well that's not
truly a bad thing that would be an
incorrect judgment and that would make
us bad as a result if we want to be good
stoics we have to recognize that care
and concern for others is part of that
so that's that's all I've got for you uh
Phil you want to do the Q a or
yeah there's a ton of stuff here yeah
and you can um okay you can see me you
can hear me I got myself back on screen
okay right thumbs up yeah that worked
okay uh yeah Greg you know I think one
of the things is I think we think some
of us come to stoicism because we're
trying to get our emo own emotions under
control right we're trying to flourish
and not be uh Embrace everyone else's
panic and what you're get is like that
next level of wait a second how can I be
a good human being and do this right I
mean I just heard you say I think I need
to be I don't need to be looking at
someone else saying you need to be more
stupid for example what I heard you say
was what I and you did not say this but
what I heard you say was a stoic does
not look at someone else and says get
over it that isn't what that's right
yeah yeah
you know and I think there's so there's
this is where Prudence enters in right
um we often like laud these stoic
virtues and we don't think about what
does this actually demand me so this
would be a case in point somebody else
is having an emotional reaction and
their emotional reaction is excessive
and it's based on some mistaken
judgments about the nature of human
beings and reality and what's good and
bad and stuff like that so I don't have
to co-sign the whole emotional reaction
right and I don't actually have to like
feel if they're being anxious about
something I don't have to have an
emotional contagion and be just as
anxious as they are I don't even have to
be anxious at all
in order to address the fact that they
are anxious and that it's not good for
them to feel that way and that I can
actually do something about that if if
the anxiety can be allayed in part by
telling them something or even just like
putting your hand on somebody's shoulder
I think that's the right stoic thing to
do but you know again we go to the
Epictetus you can groan outwardly just
don't groan inwardly with that person
and there is one um remark about
emotions that I saw in here that I did
want to address
um and you know there's so many things
here it was something about emotions
aren't really good or bad well from a
stoic perspective that's not true the
stoics actually have like
classifications there are there are
emotions that are bad
um why because they're making us unhappy
miserable right and they often tend to
lead to excessive reactions or screwed
up prioritizations on our part and then
there are emotions that are good and
recognize that that's important so we
shouldn't pretend as if like yeah
emotions don't don't have any um ethical
value that said just because you lapse
into anger or sadness or something like
that that doesn't suddenly like take you
off the stoic path and All Is Lost or
anything like that's that's normal
that's that's what's going to happen to
us we want to figure out how we can
progressively steer ourselves to having
the better emotions and having if not
you know you know stoicism is not about
repressing emotions it's about
understanding your emotions and then
getting better at you know feeling less
and less of say anger or
um you know contempt for other people or
stuff like that and you know if we want
to help other people towards that kind
of comportment when they're feeling
crappy that's not the time to say to
them oh if you were just stoic you know
this would all falling in place we want
to like we can represent that that to
them we can model that you know us again
stoic Schmucks uh we're not we're not
we're not sages right we're the cultures
is that what I am before I'm a sage I'm
just a stoic schmuck I think I could
embody that really I get it you know I
mean I get it I always say I'm a
struggler right I mean translation too
yeah I'm a struggler like the rest of
you and I'm you know I want this to be
good I want to flourish uh but sometimes
I still feel bad and sometimes I have an
appropriate responses to other people
but I hopefully never lose the idea that
I want to be a good human being and that
a lot of times involves me bringing
other peoples into my circle bringing
them closer helping them get over what
they're doing as well I think we do that
for a concern right we do that by
engaging with rather than being
standoffish and being like hey your
problems aren't my problems buddy
yeah I know right right I see you had me
on the same thing you know being from
Milwaukee I'm sure you've heard not my
circus not my monkeys and um you know
it's a very common phrase but um I think
that yeah I think it's how can I be how
can I be a good human with you and what
does it uh how can I solve for being a
good human being in this spot what does
that look like and how can I do this you
know and by the way somebody asked this
question here I'm gonna let you come
back and tap on this one last time
because there was the difference between
sympathy and empathy and I heard you you
Adam breeded in that spot but you didn't
actually say it out loud yeah this is
one of those things where there is no
like official difference between
sympathy empathy compassion all these
you know psychological terms it depends
on whose theory you're using right so a
lot of people will will like say oh
there's two kinds of empathy but you
know then others will say there's four
kinds so you know we don't want to worry
too much about that we want to think
about what is the reality that we're
concerned with and I actually used a
different term emotional contagion where
and that's another one that's used in
the psychological and philosophical
literature you know some people think
that in order to be what whether
whatever you want to call it
compassionate sympathetic empathetic I
have to be feeling the same thing that
you're feeling
and that's just not the case I can
understand the situation that you're in
even if I'm not like from the same
background
um you know haven't experienced the same
thing that's one cool thing about us
human beings is that we're capable of
that and the emotion that should go
along with that I would say is it's one
of the stoic good emotions
um what we often translate is caution
you La Bella could be translated as
concern and you know concern for the
other person and how it is that they're
they're feeling so you know again T's
example of my kids getting bullied right
now I can relate to them we all can
right because we all uh got bullied at
one point or another and probably some
of us did some bullying as well and I'll
admit that I I certainly did
um
yeah
you just gotta find some shorter people
you know
um that's the problem
but you know we we don't have to have
like had exactly the same experience to
be able to say oh man that sucks for you
um what could we do what what you know
what would help you out in this
situation
um maybe I need to go in and take a
stand
um you know with the the authorities or
something like that uh maybe nobody will
do anything well then I can at least
Express the fact that yeah that sucks
and I don't have to as a stoic say
um well strictly from a stoic
perspective nothing no harm has befallen
you right I mean that's not the time and
place to to do that maybe that'll happen
later on as we're you know as we've had
we draw upon the connection that we
formed with the person we can guide them
into that but in the in the moments we
want to actually say yeah that sucks
that's wrong that's unjust
um yeah right yeah I I agree with you
listen I I could let you suck me down
into another rabbit hole because I got
more questions of my own and maybe we'll
get to do that another time but let's
let these folks get a chance to chat
with each other and reflect upon some of
these ideas so first off uh Applause for
our pal Greg sadly here thank you for
doing this everybody put this up here